man if he was if if he was
18 if
i think he's more like 17 or 16.
really really young guy he had you know
a mask on had a hood on but i looked in
his eyes that kid he was a young kid
and he was ready to take my life
[Music]
hey everybody can you believe it i'm
still here that's right 100 days from
november 20th to february 28th my name
is pastor corey brooks and i'm living in
this tent right behind me on this
rooftop on this block called oh block is
named oh block after a young man named
od perry who was shot and killed the
gang picked up his name and the letter o
and started calling it oh block we
decided we're going to keep the o but
we're going to turn it into opportunity
block i'm really thankful tonight to
have with me a brother who
everybody in chicago knows and uh the
world is getting to know him he's an
actor he's a comedian he's into
entertainment and his name is leonard
williams and we're here tonight uh to
talk about something that happened to
him uh recently he was carjacked and for
those of you who are not aware
carjacking has been a major thing that
we're having to deal with in our city
with our young people so we want to dig
into that just a little bit today and
talk about what we can do for these kids
how important it is for us to get
involved in their lives and and uh so
i'm just gonna jump in and leonard
thanks man for coming tonight oh no i
know you affectionately everybody calls
you l yes sir yes so thank you for
coming tonight thanks for being on here
uh with us to talk about our rooftop
revelations
man what happened you know i heard the
story about you being carjacked and i
was like what l got carjacked yeah
so so tell us what happened you know we
had us a good night um nice start off
good like like a lot of people who have
tragic things happen to them the day
starts off good you never think that
it's gonna
end up the way it ended up and
uh we were at a
a a private screening for a movie
premiere
uh with dion cole shout out to dion cole
shout out to you know you know just
hanging out with good friends in the
entertainment industry you know family
people become family after you know so
long 20 years in leon rogers you know
his wife uh nicole
and uh so hanging out we left from the
movie theater
went to uh another venue or on the south
side to uh hang out with justine who's
another up-and-coming
ridiculously talented comedian and uh
as i'm leaving there
i realize my gas pump is low
my gas hand is low
mind you is it's late one two o'clock in
the morning i'm doing everything i i
know not to do right right you get gas
early you get gas you know saying start
the day off especially in chicago
especially in chicago um
you know and and in my mind i'm saying
okay i can make it home on this gas
couldn't make it home on that gas so i
drive past my usual gas station that i
normally go to if i do have to gasoline
right right
drive past that mistake number two go to
a gas station it looks like it's safe
right off the expressway big truck stop
uh in gary indiana
and
i go in to pay for my gas grab some
snacks
come back out
and i notice
the uh well first the pump was moving
really slow right so in my mind being
from chicago this is how people get
carjacked let me go sit in the car
you know i'm going to sit in the car and
wait
as i'm going to get back in the car
notice that the car and at the pump next
to me black tented out nissan knew a
model
it's just sitting there right
and i say to myself nah that's not how
that's gonna happen
and i really heard god say yeah just
breathe
three words yeah just breathe
at which point the car hits the gas
cuts off and cuts off any movement i
could have had if i would have got in my
car
stops in front of my car the young guy
comes out the passenger side with the
gun drawn uh straight to my face
at but by the time he got out the car i
already had my hands up because i
remember i heard god say yeah that's
happening brief so i already had my
hands up
he asked me to unlock my phone so i
unlock the phone
and i i drop my key fob and i say it's
yours
i turned around and walked off
you know what unlock your phone what
what what's that about me why would a
brother carjacking their car i know why
but i want them to understand why i
unlock your phone these kids are well
versed and they checklist and what
they're doing they're kids
but they know what they're doing i'm
gonna say this some of y'all might be
mad but they this generation this is the
generation that grew up playing grand
theft auto they're really playing grand
theft auto in real life
and so he knew to take my phone so he
could turn it off and that way i
couldn't use
ah you know i couldn't find it i
couldn't track it and i couldn't call
the police right away it gave him enough
time to get to expressway
get gone
um and it it's been off he hadn't turned
it back on man let me ask you this how
do you think he was and the reason why i
asked that is because we got a lot of
young kids you know we had a case where
a 10 and an 11 year old
uh carjacked somebody here recently and
so how old do you think these kids were
and what do you think is going on with
all of this
man if he was if if he was
18 if
i think he's more like 17 to 16.
really really young guy he had you know
a mask on had a hood on but i looked in
his eyes that kid he was a young kid
and uh he was ready to take my life
um i saw that in his eyes too
but they have a checklist they know what
they're doing and you know they're gonna
take your phone they're gonna
take your vehicle they're gonna move
around and a lot of stuff a lot of the
times you know back in the 90s there was
a market for vehicles and they were
selling these vehicles chopping them
down sending the parts overseas these
kids ain't getting no money they joyride
or they're doing hits
in your vehicle
they take your vehicle and go to
somebody else's block
y'all that's just how ideas sometimes
we're in the hood so sometimes people
give us a shout out
i love y'all too
love it man
sorry
no no worries man uh
you know that's a blessing i'm glad to
hear love because you know i want to put
my gun out
[Laughter]
wait a minute
he already said love all right cool
relax
um something like that happens to you it
makes you um it heightens your awareness
yeah and i've always moved with a
heightened awareness anyway so that's
why i knew what was happening while it
was happening
um
but i was in it at that point absolutely
let me ask you this
before we close this part
what can we do to help these young
brothers man because at the end of the
day
it's brothers like me and you
i believe got to get involved in these
young brothers lives a lot of them
are missing their fathers they come from
single-parent households and i'm not
making any excuses i'm just giving the
facts
and i think it's important especially
for brothers like ourselves that you
know you've been an entertainer a
comedian an actor
it's important for brothers like you to
get back involved in the community can
you just
talk about that for a second and now i'm
gonna tell you something this is this is
why i don't i don't hold no malice
toward these kids man these they
shorties right
um
and i'm glad i i wasn't
caring at the time too
you know to to to to fire upon them i
don't want to take nobody baby out of
here um
what we can do and what a lot of us are
doing because i myself i've been
involved in the community for a long
time you know shout out to
uh we're anita taylor jamal smalls i
used to work for a foundation called
dime chow and i taught after school team
inglewood before it was urban prep
um
we just got to keep showing love
and keep being an example uh these kids
they they're they're raising themselves
you know because the parents that are at
home they're working really hard and
they they
they're not home enough
to raise these kids these kids a lot of
these kids growing up with their
grandparents who are way too old to deal
with all this young energy and to
correct certain things they just let
them do what they what they want to do a
lot of times so you know for us as as as
brothers as men as black men
uh just keep showing love and showing
them there's a different way
i don't have to look at you as the enemy
when i see you in the street you don't
have to look at me as the enemy we need
to to
to do this in love but correction is
necessary tell these kids hey that ain't
how you're supposed to do it that's
right i thank god for all the old heads
that that cuffed me i'm talking about
from the streets to the pulpit right
they all pulled me to the side and said
that's not how you're supposed to do it
let's do this differently absolutely
man that's what it's really all about i
want to thank you for coming by tonight
and uh
sharing on our rooftop revelations yes
it's always a blessing to have you uh
come by i know you're real busy and uh
i appreciate it listen that's what it's
all about we got to get into the lives
of these young people
we can stop the crime we don't have to
wait on government to do it for us
we got to take the initiative we got to
do the work we got to do everything we
can to show these kids that we affirm
them we accept them give them the
attention that they need to pull them
out of the lifestyle that they're in and
give them an opportunity that's why
we're trying to build this community
center so as i always say
thank you all for tuning in to rooftop
revelations and until tomorrow i'll see
you then peace
you